the 2024 TV season holds more soups Sith
and Squid games with some promising news
stories also in the mix here's a look at
the shows that are going to blow
everyone away in
2024 Moana is back but this time for
television in Moana the series The
Animated musical series will continue
telling moana's story following the
events of the 2016 film Disney plus
hasn't revealed much about the upcoming
show show but as managing editor of
Nerdist Alisha loots noted to USA Today
moana's compassion makes her an
interesting character considering the
way she helped the goddess teiti instead
of trying to destroy her loots said
there's Beauty and the empathy of
moana's response Moana was able to see
and connect to understand the problem
it's a powerful thing to see in a
children's movie especially between two
women regardless of where the plot takes
her viewers can expect moana's core
character traits to shine through the
series will be helmed by encanto's David
G Derek Jr rather than Ron Clemens and
John musker who directed the 2016
animated feature alii cavalo is
returning as the title character but no
other casting announcements have yet
been made so it's unclear if the likes
of Dwayne Johnson will return for the
series it's actually Maui Shape Shifter
demigod of the Wind and Sea hero of men
Disney could use this opportunity to
throw some new characters in the mix
regardless the series promises to be an
exciting Adventure following the release
of the Robert patson led the Batman in
2022 it's full steam ahead on Matt
Reeves batverse the film which also
starred Zoe Kravitz Paul Dano and
Jeffrey Wright introduced viewers to a
new version of the penguin played by
Irish actor Colin frell his performance
garnered so much praise that it wasn't
long before Reeves was setting up a SP
spin-off series based on the character
and he told collider that the series
will be instrumental in setting up the
sequel to his 2022 film adding that he's
super excited about the evolution of
this new universe oh so you're a big man
now frell expressed his excitement about
the series telling collider I read the
first episode which is just so tasty and
so unusual as the character was on the
page and what Matt Reeves kind of
envisioned when he was thinking up this
iteration of the bang up of Oz not much
else has been announced about the plot
or the cast of the miniseries but
deadline did report that Christen milot
has been cast as Sophia Falcone the
daughter of former Crime Boss Carmine
Falcone who was killed in the Batman the
series began filming in New York in
March 2023 before production was shut
down by the wga strike in June the
penguin is still expected to have a 2024
release on
Max Korean horror survival Dr drama
squid game became an instant hit on
Netflix when it dropped in 2021 the
show's protagonist s Gian survived the
Twisted game show while his competitors
were executed but he's been totally
changed by the experience this has given
Creator Wang dyak an interesting way to
move the show forward as guan's more
selfless nature pushes him toward a new
mystery rather than a family reunion
with his daughter dong hak explained to
The Hollywood Reporter season 2 is going
to be about what that new guon is going
to do and how things will unfold with
this new kind of character do you think
squid game could keep going for more
seasons Beyond season two it's tough to
tell maybe maybe not dong Yak kept quiet
on the pars of the plot but shared with
variety that he planned to finish
writing the new season by the end of
2022 in order to bring it to screens in
2024 he lived up to his word and
principal filming began in July in South
Korea where it's expected to wrap around
May
2024 reboots are having a moment but
there's something extra special about
bringing a beloved animated series into
the liveaction world based on the
Nickelodeon show of the same name Avatar
The Last Airbender will come to Netflix
in 2024 the show has big shoes to fill
the original animated series which ran
on Nick from 2005 to 2008 has retained a
100% critic approval rating on Rotten
Tomatoes but show Runner Albert Kim
thinks they're up to the task telling to
Doom a liveaction version cannot only
Faithfully translate what had been done
in animation it can bring a rich new
visual Dimension to a fantastic World
additionally Gordon Cormier who plays
the show's 12-year-old protagonist said
this liveaction version brings to life
everything fans love about the Animated
Series as the title suggests Ang is the
last air bender in a land separated by
the four elements the water tribe Earth
Kingdom Fire Nation and air Nomads as an
Avatar Ang is more powerful than most
but he still has a lot to learn before
he can stop the Fire Nation from taking
control of everything Cormier is joined
by Gua Ando as qara Ian Oley as Saka
Dallas Leu as Zuko Paul Sang Lee as iro
Elizabeth Yu as aula and Daniel Day Kim
as fired Lord oai rounding out the
central cast the series will consist of
10 hourlong
episodes The Walking Dead Universe has
been expanding for years the Show's
first spin-off 2015's Fear The Walking
Dead was followed up by The Walking Dead
World Beyond and tales of the Walking
Dead although the Original Series has
now ended airing its dramatic final
episode on AMC on November 20th 2022
there are plenty of stories in The
Walking Dead Universe left to explore
two new shows The Walking Dead dead City
and the walk in Dead Daryl Dixon bring
back fan favorite characters like Maggie
Negan and darl in
2023 Andrew Lincoln and Deni gerera are
also set to reprise their roles as Rick
and mown in The Walking Dead the ones
who live which is set to Premiere in
2024 The Walking Dead season 11 finale
briefly teased what is expected to be
the show's starting point with Rick
disappearing into a helicopter and
Michonne searching for him on horseback
their long separation has been
challenging but the show's new teaser
confirms that viewers will see their
epic Love Story continue as they reunite
in AMC's six episode series Lincoln and
gerera will have more creative control
this time around though both actors
serve as executive producers and gerera
is also credited as a writer on the
spin-off additionally Scott M gimple the
chief content officer of The Walking
Dead universe will be the showrunner
Netflix Wednesday ended up being one of
the biggest shows of 2022 with Tim
Burton behind the camera and Smallville
riding Duo Alfred GFF and Miles Miller
Penning the script it's hardly a
surprise and playing the titular Adams
is Jenna Ortega who delivers Snappy
dialogue and perfect onliners in every
scene without blinking of course I'm
sure it wouldn't be too challenging to
play a uplifting Fleetwood Mac
mity as long as you promis to hang me as
a witch afterwards
Ortega is joined by stars like Emma
Myers Hunter Duan gwendelyn Christie and
Katherine Zita Jones for a thrilling
season that concludes with the teen
detective outing former Wednesday Adams
actor Christina reach's Marilyn
Thornhill as the infamous Laurel Gates
of course it didn't wrap up too neatly
there's still the question of
Wednesday's stalker to attend to season
2 is expected to air around October 2024
as for what else viewers might see at
never more Academy next season Wednesday
will be as dark and dramatic as ever
speaking on the tonight's show starring
Jimmy Fallon Ortega teased we want to up
kind of the horror aspect a little bit
and then get Wednesday out of the
Romantic situation and just let her be
her own individual the recruit follows
CIA lawyer Owen Hendrick played by Noah
centineo as he gets swept up into a life
or death Mission involving Max mlad an
untrustworthy former CIA asset the 8
episod series quickly reached number one
on Netflix after its December 2022
Premiere the Chicago cent times gave it
a ringing endorsement saying flashy
funny and action-packed the recruit is a
slick conection that pulls off the
difficult beat of juggling a multiplot
Twist fill Globe trotting storyline that
Carin all over the place and yet is
relatively easy and quite fun to follow
that review was followed by the
announcement that the crime action
series was renewed for a second season
coming to the streamer in 2024 season 2
will no doubt be busy answering the
question who is Carolina after the
mysterious Russian woman shot her
alleged mother Max and kidnapped Owen in
the final moments of the season 1 finale
fans may be in the dark for now but
showrunner Alexi Holly confirmed that he
plans to kick things up a notch in
season 2 The Night agent premiered on
Netflix in 2023 to a favorable 74%
critical consensus on Rotten Tomatoes
and an even higher audience rating the
first season of the Spy Thriller follows
FBI agent Peter Southerland as he
uncovers an increasingly complicated
conspiracy about a highlevel mole in the
White House the finale ends with Peter
saving the president's life only to be
left with a mysterious job offer as the
show heads into season 2 you have no
idea what you're getting
into however there's a big twist on the
way in season 2 which has been greenlit
by Netflix and is set to reach the
streamer in 2024 the night agent
showrunner Shan Ryan previously told
collider That season 1 was a
self-contained story but in a more
recent interview with comic book Ryan
said viewers should expect major changes
next season revealing it does not take
place in the DC area which is where
season 1 took place so we'll be in a
different part of the world exploring
different characters than we had in
season 1 Ryan confirmed that season 2
would still be centered around basso's
character knowing that they set the bar
so high with season 1 Ryan and the
creative team are going all out to
create a fresh story for season 2 but
that doesn't mean they've ruled out
having a few familiar faces return
meaning that Peter's love interest Rose
Lin might not be gone for good Vikings
Valhalla is returning to screens for an
adventurous third season in the first
quarter of 2024 a teaser trailer for the
new season was released shortly after
season 2 dropped it confirms that leaf
Erikson frus Eric stter and Harold
searson will be back but also suggests
some pretty major changes ahead
including a possible time Jump the
teaser showed fratus with a young
redheaded boy who might be her inh
Herald son however whether fratus and
Harold have reconciled during the
missing time after she HIIT her
pregnancy from him in season 2 remains
to be seen the teaser also confirms that
leaf and Harold will reunite for a
treacherous Journey viewers can expect
the Vikings to leave Scandinavia and
travel to lands unknown and undoubtedly
there will be some Fierce battles along
the way as they explore new lands the
characters may start to experience a
clash of cultures as Christianity takes
root in Scandinavia the gods know the
truth false
gods Additionally the show will welcome
some new cast members namely Croatian
American actor Goran visnich is set to
make his debut in the series as Eric the
Red Leaf and frus his father high
potential is a new detective drama
coming to ABC in 2024 it stars Caitlyn
olssen of its always sunny and
Philadelphia of Fame as single mom
Morgan Who moonlights as a private eye
according to the show's official
synopsis Morgan's talent for solving
unusual crimes leads to a partnership
with kedc a non-nonsense detective
played by Daniel Sanada the show is
based on the popular French series
potential ual or HPI if it follows suit
viewers can expect for Morgan to be a
feisty character who pushes back against
Authority in hbi Morgan has a60 IQ and
is asked to partner with detectives to
catch highly intelligent criminals high
potential is written and executive
produced by Drew GD who got his start as
a staff writer on Buffy the Vampire
Slayer before going on to write the
screenplay for the Martian and serve as
showrunner on the Daredevil series
alongside olssen and Sada the cast
includes Javis Leslie as Daphne Dennis
OG Dennis as Lev Oz Osman Amir J as AA
Matthew lamb as Elliot and Judy Reyes as
Selena high potential was the first ABC
pilot to be ordered for the 2023 2024 TV
season and with the lineup behind the
scenes it's sure to be a gripping drama
Netflix is no stranger to adapting books
for the small screen with shows like
Bridgerton bringing the streaming giant
huge success one of the platforms bookto
screen adaptations coming out in 2024 is
the Thriller deliver me the series comes
from Swedish author menen parison
galito's best-selling novel by the same
name the author's previous novel
quicksand was adapted by the streamer in
2019 and she will reunite with Freda ASP
and Fatima varos the producer writer Duo
she worked with back then additionally
gito will make her screenwriting debut
with the series in Netflix's press
release announcing the new show gito
says I am so proud that this will also
be my debut as a screenwriter I thought
Netflix's adaptation of quicksand was
the best thing that would ever happen to
me professionally but I'm beginning to
think that this is even bigger according
to the synopsis deliver me begins as a
14-year-old boy lays face down in front
of a swing set as his life drains out of
the gaping wound in his head behind him
stands his best friend a warm gun in his
trembling hand
the series will explore difficult
subjects such as children committing
violence and how that comes about
whether it's from social alienation
poverty or negligence newcomer Ali
strand plays dog the boy who pulls the
trigger and he's joined by Julien
Carlson Solomon y yaser Hassan and
Midsummer star Henrik
Norland 2024 is going to be a banner
year for Netflix fans as the streamer
has plenty of exciting TV shows lined up
that are sure to blow you away along
with new shows premiering there are a
number of returning shows including the
fan favorite drama you which will
conclude with its Fifth and final season
we all know there are many Loose Ends
from Joe's past the last dramatic
installment of the series will see Joe
played by pen Badgley returned for one
last murder spree it's inevitable that
his total victim count which currently
sits at 18 that we know about will go up
again one unsuspecting victim May well
be his new love interest Kate who's also
Al expected to return for season 5 now
that he's back in New York after living
in London under the pseudonym Professor
Jonathan Moore showrunner Sarah gamble
plans to shake the show up with a mix of
new and returning characters that
includes Joe's old neighbor Ellie played
by Jenna Ortega in an interview with
people gamble said we have ideas for
Ellie if her schedule allows her to
visit us again as for other familiar
faces the U Creator teased that there's
room for any past characters to appear
dead or alive saying any character who's
not dead who knows anything about Joe
it's fair game to try to exert any
justice and any character who is dead
Joe has a really active
imagination ever since Pedro Pascal
debuted as the Mandalorian in 2019
Disney plus has been delighting Star
Wars fans with a slew of liveaction TV
shows fans have been especially excited
about 2023 Ahsoka which gives the
titular jet die more liveaction screen
time than ever before however 2024 also
promises an exciting new adventure with
the acolyte which is set in a time
period never before depicted in a Star
Wars movie or series it takes place
around a 100 years before The Phantom
Menace during the high Republic the
Golden Age of the Jedi I play a Mary
Allen an elder Jedi Master it's
initially an idealic time where the Jedi
Knights don't have to use their
lightsabers to battle anyone but of
course that doesn't last while the Sith
are supposed to be gone a mysterious
Dark Side power is on the rise according
to the show's official synopsis a former
Padawan will reunite with her Jedi
Master to investigate a series of crimes
but the forces they confront are more
Sinister than they ever anticipated
build as a mystery thriller the accolite
features some familiar faces including
Daphne Kean Manny jento Lee Jung Jay and
Amanda Stenberg jento revealed that
viewers can expect a lot of action in
this Sith Le story with plenty of
lightsaber battles thanks to their
Samurai training referring to an iconic
scene in The Phantom Menace jento told
Entertainment Weekly you love the
sequence with Quon and o1 and Darth Maul
yeah I think you're going to enjoy this
[Music]
show